The world is awash in data.
It is growing at exponential rates.
People have coined the term big data,
to refer to this phenomenon,
but often can't agree on what it means.
What separates big data from everything else?
Cesar Hidalgo at MIT Media Lab,
says that to qualify for this distinction,
data must be big in size, resolution and scope.
To re-frame this idea,
in a way that is directly relevant to transforming health care delivery systems,
data must represent many patients and providers.
It must do so in detail,
and as we will now discuss,
it must be combined with other data to give the real world context,
within which patients live and get sick,
care is delivered, and the delivery system operates.